على كل من جده نورنا شبيه الفنان طلال
مداح عيسى تركي السيد عيسى اهلا بك معنا
بصباح العربيه منورنا بوجودك شكرا على
تواجدك معنا
اهلا وسهلا اهلا بك اول شيء بدنا نعرف متى
اكتشفت هذا الشبه الكبير بينك وبين الراحل
طلال
[موسيقى]
يعني بنفسي انا ما عندي يعني علم بشبه هذا
جت فتره من الفترات تقريبا قبل 17 سنه او
18 سنه تقريبا
كل ما اجي اخرج في اي محفل ولا في
[موسيقى]
يعني مناسبه متعلقه بالاصحاب
الناس يعني
تبدا ايش تتقرب لي وتتصور معاي انت شبهك
فما كنت يعني كنت متوقع انه هذا الشبح
حيكون بالحجم هذا يعني
طيب استاذ عيسى تمنيت انه يكون عندك صوت
جميل قريب لصوت الراحل المبدع طلال مداح
ومثلا قد تمثل دور من اعماله اعمال
مستقبليه مثلا
والله صوت طلال مداح اجمع عليه الجميع
يعني على اساس انه كان موهبه من الله
سبحانه وتعالى للفنان الكبير رحمه الله
عليه
كان يجذب قلوب الناس كثيرا يعني
كنت الواحد كان يتمنى انه بصراحه يكون
عنده صوت طالع المداح
هذه طبعا مو بيدي الواحد يعني طيب سيدي
عيسى انتشر لك بقوه جدا فيديو وانت تتحدث
مع ابنه الرحم طلال مداح شو اللي دار
بينكم وكيف كان شعورها بس شافتك
والله ابنه الفنان طلال مدح نغم اصرت على
مقابلتي بحيث كنت اتحاشى انا على اساس
الموقف
اللي صار يعني
موقف مؤثر بيني وبينك
ولما قابلتني انصدمت وانبهرت من الشبه
اللي بيني وبين والدها يعني طيب لدرجه
انها قالت نسخه يعني
لا تاكد وتزيد هذا الشبح يعني
هل اللي انت حاططهم كانت مقصوده انه تكون
شبيهه بالتي كان يستعملها الراحل طلال
مداح
لا والله بالعكس هذه انا من زمان معي
النظاره وبيني وبينك وفي نظاره ثانيه يعني
اطارات ثانيه تختلف
[موسيقى]
قاصد
عيسى في مواقف كذا
المداح في مواقف ضلت راسخه فذكرتك
اكيد كل ما طلع يعني في
يعني في الشارع او في مكان منتزه ومجمع
تجاري او حاجه زي كذا فالناس يعني تجي
تزدحم عليه واللي يبغى يتصور
يلتقط صور معايا
طيب لو عرض عليك
دور في فيلم يحكي عن الراحل طلال مداح
توافق انك تمثل
والله
سرور الواحد يعني يقبل الكلام
تسلم شكرا جزيلا
الله يسلمك
شكرا لك سيد عيسى